pour faire le point on retrouve à paris
sauf imméritée et les maîtres de
conférences à l'université paris
dauphine et chercheur au centre de
géopolitique de l'énergie et des
matières premières bonsoir madame
méritait bonsoir diriez vous que déjà la
reprise de l'approvisionnement de gaz
russe par nord stream 1 c'est un pas
dans la bonne direction que pensez vous
de cette reprise
alors même si le gaz revient il revient
pour l'instant quantité limitée puisque
on est encore à 30 ou 40 % du flux
habituel et donc on a toujours quand
même ce risque de pénurie au niveau du
gaz et donc on le sait pour l'hiver qui
arrive mais aussi d hiver prochain le
stress il est toujours là donc en ce qui
concerne le gaz naturel vous parlez de
stress plusieurs pays effectivement
s'inquiètent pour leur approvisionnement
pour les prochains mois quel pays en
particulier est le plus fragile en ce
moment le plus vulnérable si moscou je
vais revenir à ordonner la fermeture du
robinet carrément
alors la situation en fait elle est
assez compliqué parce que même si un
pays dépend peu du gaz pour sa
production d'électricité
les économies sont liées et donc vous
allez avoir des conséquences économiques
et financières dans la zone européenne
et donc vous avez certains états qui
utilisent beaucoup le gaz pour produire
de l'électricité
ça va 2 8% jusqu'à 88% donc on voit bien
que les situations elles sont très
différentes mais c'est vrai que
naturellement j'aurais tendance à dire
que nous regardons tous l'allemagne qui
est quand même la première économie
européenne et que si la situation en
allemagne ne s'améliore pas l'ensemble
de la zone va européenne va être touché
oui d'ailleurs la commission européenne
a proposé hier un plan qui vise à
économiser 15 % de la demande de gaz à
court terme donc réduire la consommation
les états membres et c'est de remplir
évidemment leurs réserves pour traverser
l'hiver est-ce que ça va suffire si on
en vient à faire cesser le flux de nord
stream
alors pour vous donner
un ordre d'idée 15% de réduction c'est
un peu près
45 milliards de mètres cubes de gaz
c'est un peu près la consommation de la
france en une année donc c'est entre eux
en plus entre le 1er août et le 31 mars
cette décision ce plan il fait partie
d'un plan plus global qu'on appelle les
trois aces
sobriété solidarité et substitution et
c'est vrai que les états membres ont pas
tous bien réagi à l annonce de cette
réduction de 15 % puisque certains n'ont
pas été consultés et les situations sont
encore une fois bien différente mais en
même temps vous avez des états qui sont
déjà allés au delà de ces 15% comme la
finlande et donc si aujourd'hui on a nos
stocks au niveau européen qui sont en
train de se remplir ils sont encore à un
niveau inférieur à il y a un an et on
n'est pas encore assez 80 85 % dont on a
besoin on est plutôt vers les 60 65 %
donc on le sait que nos stocks se
remplissent moins vite qu'on a encore
des problèmes de stocks et que oui la
situation reste préoccupante pour un
très grand nombre d' économie européenne
est encore une fois parce que nous
sommes liés interconnectés par les
réseaux mais également économiquement et
même si on arrivait à remplir les
réservoirs à plein d'ici les prochains
mois madame méritait ce qu'on serait
capable de passer l'hiver
tout dépend de la température
tout dépend de la température tout
dépend illégalement du vent si le vent
souffle et qu'on a un hiver doux fch on
devrait pouvoir passer l'hiver mais le
stress il est vraiment il va au delà
c'est à dire que c'est vraiment sur la
production d'électricité qui est pour
nous un élément central au niveau
européen pour le chauffage évidemment si
vous prenez l'allemagne à un
consommateur sur deux un ménage surtout
pardon est chauffé par le gaz vous avez
toute l'économie allemande derrière qui
va être touchée et on le sait que même
si
nos noces capacité de stockage se
remplissent c'est quelque part reculer
pour mieux sauter à un moment donné et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on cherche
des sources d'approvisionnement
alternatives on pense à l'esj et à
l'azerbaïdjan guerre ou pas madame
méritait est-ce que c'est fini la
dépendance à la russie
alors faut un petit peu remettre en
contexte c'est à dire que la russie
s'est historiquement notre premier
fournisseur énergétique en gaz en
électrique en pétrole et en charbon mais
depuis des années l'europe est celle de
limiter sa dépendance à la russie et là
effectivement nous avons un petit réveil
qui est absolument brutal pour nous
faire accélérer à la fois nos baisses de
consommation pour réduire notre
dépendance par rapport à la russie mais
également pour le changement climatique
donc là ne baisse de consommation la
sobriété on aurait dû le faire et bien
là on est obligé de le faire on est
scellé oui en ce qui concerne
l'électricité en france en particulier
madame méritée on peut pas tout mettre
le le sur le don de la guerre en ukraine
n'est ce pas rapidement terminant quels
sont les enjeux
alors c'est vrai que le cas de la france
est intéressant puisqu'on a un bouquet
énergétique qui est différent des autres
pays européens
notamment sur l'électricité on va être
très clair 70 % de l'électricité
produite en france est d'origine
nucléaire 12 % c'est de l'hydro et 8 %
c'est du gaz donc on voit bien que on
est peu dépendant au gaz mais en plus la
russie n'est pas notre premier
fournisseur en france pour le gaz donc
on utilise peu de gaz pour produire de
l'électricité
et on est peu dépendant la russie mais
malgré tout la situation et les
critiques en france pour l'électricité
en effet avec la crise qu vide on a dû
un petit peu
malheureusement retardé ce qu'on appelle
le grand carénage c'est la maintenance
de certaines de certains réacteurs
nucléaires et donc aujourd'hui on a la
moitié de nos réacteurs qui sont à
l'arrêt soit pour des raisons de
maintenance soit parce que
malheureusement nous avons découvert de
la corrosion sur certains est donc
aujourd'hui vous ajoutez en plein été
une sécheresse donc la non utilisation
de certains réacteurs et la non
utilisation
d'hydroélectricité on se retrouve cette
année avec la production du clair la
plus faible en france depuis des
décennies donc on est avec un manque
d'électricité aujourd'hui donc vous
imaginez bien que nos pour l'hiver oui
le stress arrive également mais de
grands défis énergétiques en europe
merci beaucoup pour vos explications
madame héritait je vous en prie merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit